[Music]
you really want to know what love is
yeah yes tell us more than anything in
the world Ron well it's really quite
simple it's kind of
like
[Music]
that sounds kind of crazy crazy crazy
crazy crazy
crazy little ham eggs coming at you hold
on people we got your
[Music]
dles we got it
now
[Music]
news team
[Applause]
[Music]
Assemble
you
[Music]
that's baby making music that's what
that
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
you play jazz blue Hi D would everyone
love to hear R BG play some y
[Applause]
[Music]
FL get on stage now okay little
honestly I'm not prepared I really am
not at all yes this is a surprise tell
you guys eem Shakedown eat flat keep the
symol flashy and uh Jared let's take the
Baseline for a
[Music]
walk
have
[Music]
all
[Applause]
that sounds kind of crazy
[Music]
czy
boy that escalated quickly I mean that
really got out of hand fast fast fast
[Music]
fast